hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to slender 7th Street ah my
head hurts the throbbing pain please
make it stop
I don't know if you can see that by its
a loading screen there's a little bit of
dialogue there now I couldn't get this
sponsored by white boi sevenths I'm
guessing that's where the name came from
project lead March teen environment
artist ray Burgess Jake Brooks I didn't
get the last name 7th Street ah
oh hello well this doesn't look good
ah I saw the development pictures
showing that it was outside hey hey wait
a minute this is all 7th Street alright
so looks like we got a general not a bad
layout of the town here seems like a box
bin city I like it better it looks much
more detailed than the previous sonner
games oh hello hello Katie okay okay oh
I like this hear my heartbeat a lot
sooner
hi I think it said pages and I'm looking
for so we're looking for pages again ah
ah I like this too Redick Boulevard it
kind of gives you aa there's a page
that's bright bright and obvious it kind
of gives you landmarks and street signs
that you can kind of tell where you are
that's really cool takes over your mind
I'm aware I'm aware of how slender works
I'm I try to move in a you know a square
pattern see if I can get this all going
that sounds very different from the last
one from the previous thumps don't stare
I know buddy I think they did a lot of
changes to the sounds because it's
definitely more environmental dammit
what the hell whoa whoa whoa
god damn what the hell jeez oh he's
still there holy hell oh no don't tell
me he's a lot more aggressive in this
one always watch Zion that's no joke man
no joke oh man the sound is definitely
improved
I'd like it I like it a lot actually I
don't like it but you know it's okay all
right just follow the rules
don't look back pressing forward
looking for pages layout doesn't seem as
square as I first thought it would be I
think I went through one quadrant of a
city just now and I'm moving into the
second quarter ah I got three pages in
that last quadrant hopefully I'll get
two or three here and then thought I see
two right there get this one run over
that one no face still sees I know how
slender works four of eight oh man Oh
what is that what is that what is that
what is that paleis man black suit I
know I know I know don't get caught on
that okay that's the second quadrant
what is that Eric music looks like your
music ooh oh oh man I like it I don't I
I like it's good it's well done it's not
good it's just well done definitely
improved Oh in hahaha number six don't
stop where he takes you I know I know
fringe is definitely much faster no
escape ha hi blue I beg I beg to differ
on the Han regard oh no oh no oh no oh
no I think I've come out to where I was
and I haven't found the last note is
that red tick boulevard oh no I don't
know where the last notice I don't know
oh I missed something
oh god I missed something
I missed something I missed something ah
oh no oh no oh no oh no
I've got like shivers oh I got pins and
needles out of these well it's got to be
here it's got to be right here somewhere
oh no this work came in off of the wall
there oh I've been through here I've
been through here Oh God
what's with that noise the frickin noise
Oh sting went through this way I think I
found a note right there I got to go
over here or something no I've been
through here
what
who's the warning you're right there oh
my dad is this worse is like worse
Oh God oh man I thought at first you
know I was entering the game like ah and
now the center game I'm gonna see the Oh
God
huh boys in there No
oh yeah all right I'll do it again
ah my head it hurts the throbbing pain
please they can stop oh man I was like I
don't know what it was with that music
but he was like I had like well pin
pricks all over my hands in the arms and
like all over my scalp and oh I don't
like this
oh it broke thank God
fresh three two one boom Oh
oh my boys seventh Street Shan quaint
ins sound engineer that was a Jake guy
done a good job Jake
you're done good trick he just was like
I didn't have any warning or maybe there
wasn't worried maybe that was that thing
that sound was like him getting close to
me okay I'm gonna go down this way first
and there are obviously quadrants of the
city there might actually be six around
look down these
make sure I cover everything
five Callistus I don't have glow sticks
on this one looking everywhere making
sure I got everything covered that
always blocked up okay here we go all
right starting down my run
maybe I run a serpentine pattern through
the area
no need a run just need to be nice and
calm okay the first one number one I
can't believe I got up to seven the
first time but man that was bad
oh it was bad I don't like that how like
suddenly gets dark every end of times it
confuses me cuz I don't know if he's
like about to get me or what he's number
two the city is definitely you know more
compact I don't know if that's a good
thing I'm gonna try to like look around
every corner of each quadrant before I
move on if I don't see it up turn around
go start on my run to the next one
aha no no no no no no uh-uh uh-uh
no no no no no no no no no no takes over
your mind how weird buzzing let me knees
close
I don't know what things mean anymore I
don't know what everything needs anymore
I don't know I mean these pages are
bright enough that it's pretty obvious
all right so far so decent pretty dark
I'm nervous he's like right behind me
I'm very nervous
hmm what stop that please stop it stop
it stop it okay there's nothing down
there I'm gonna go ooh stop it I don't
like that I don't like that noise I do
not like that noise
I don't like it it sounds like there are
things right behind me Jebus help me
help me Tom Cruise use your black magic
to save me Oh nor do you do I've missed
some things haven't I oh that I haven't
I'm almost certain that I have there
like maybe there's one on the okay no
there's not hmm let's go let's go let's
go let's go let's go go let's go let's
go let's go okay there's another one oh
man I know I've missed some I know I
have oh it's bad okay there's two oh
this will bring me up to seven oh crap
and then I I don't have one I don't
think I have anymore
I think there's a last water Hey let's
go let's go let's go let's go let's go
you go go go go go
huh oh my god
oh thank you oh I got caught on that
corner oh no this is where I started no
this is where I started
do you bring new dick oh wow
I can't run at all anymore my Sprint's
are all spread it out how do I escape
the city how how I see you later over
there
ah I don't know how I do do I don't know
how oh you bastard you tell me to do
these things and you don't tell me you
have okay obviously I used sprint way
too much
okay crashed again so I don't know
what's up with those crashes that man
three two one boom oh alright let's give
it one more try I can do this I know I
can okay I know I don't know I don't
know where it digs so I'm just gonna try
to go the edge like maybe any any of
them you can go to and it'll be fine but
I don't know I don't know I was like
looking for like a door or bus or
something one of the buses okay I can do
this I don't think the spawns are
randomized I think they're just there so
I'm not gonna sprint at all until I get
like seven but hopefully I know where
they are so I'll be able to let's just
give this one more sure let's do this
okay know where they are I know where to
go I know where to find them
I know what to do I'm actually let me
look here like if I were to escape the
city would probably be in that one but I
don't know okay
ah does that pay to them as I'll get
that not actually I'll get that one
first cuz i know cuz this is the only
one that's kind of inside everything
else is on the outskirts not gonna
sprint not gonna panic I know that I'm
okay at least for a bit okay number two
yes ever stop homie
I don't know how the makers will even
have to keep getting me but I'm not I'm
not in favor of Oh what do you do there
that's where I need to be your dick you
didn't even have tentacles in wrong with
you get a little impotent okay that's
number three the only other tricky one
everything else is free straight forward
so I just go that's three in this one
they'll be three in the next one and
I'll get it and then I'll get I'll just
go to a like an edge or a wall or try to
get out as soon I don't even see I'm
looking around for a triangle
supposing escape but I don't see
anything I don't I
not okay there's the next one it's
pretty much straight forward from there
on out stay for there on out okay okay
all right I got this I got this I got
this I guess I got it I got it I got it
takes over your mind duh takes over your
bar there's a noise god the music and
this one is so much better so much
better Jake you did an incredible job on
the sounds don't stare I know I know
staring has hardly become a problem in
these slender games like staring is the
least of my concerns
head on apply directly to the forehead
really head on apply directly to the
forehead
head on apply directly to the forehead
head on I mean you know that advertising
campaign works when everyone knows what
the hell why is it getting dark that
darkness that darkness creeping up
around do I need to sprint here okay all
right whatever
I know there's two in a row after this
so I think I might want to start
hurrying up now oh oh
bric-a-brac I sprinted when I probably
did I don't know what that was
there's a light bulb breaking I know
what that was or piece of glass okay
there's one and there's two and then I'm
out of here
I don't know where to go though one am
too high then I'm out of here I don't
know where to go though afterwards gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme
just get that I can't say a thing where
do I go Oh
oh my I did it hmm I'm like shocked I
didn't even know that I could do it that
was it huh hello chatter a second puppy
my puppy was in the same room whoo
celebratory puppy looking better ha ha
ha oh no mommy you don't like being
picked up do you you don't act leave it
forever ever ever
all right thank you all so much for
watching that was awesome go support the
website go donate to them they're great
guys they make great maps that was fun
Oh fun as heck so thank you all so much
for watching and click the link in the
description below
a slender reaction compilation down
below other videos that I've done other
slender videos that I've done thank you
all so much for watching and as always
I'll see you in the next video bye